the only way to get better at networking  is realizing why you're scared of  people's judgment it's something I deal  with it's not about a technique it's why  do you actually worry that if Dustin you  why does that make you feel bad you need  to figure that out let me give you the  secret it doesn't [ __ ] matter you  [ __ ] us then yeah right just saying  [ __ ] you Dustin say it sounds good it'll  make me happy it'll make my day  sorry about that listen to me if you can  remember that moment and realize all of  them are Dustin yeah it's not like [ __ ]  you really it's like don't value  someone's opinion about you more than  the value that you put on yourself about  you I know I gotta do that so start  practicing what happens next you  practice you like really practice yeah  you just go and actually Network and  just do it and like feel the pain and  the awkwardness until it's gone